-Guys,
the pandemic is spiking,
so it's still very important to
wear a mask when you go outside,
but there are a lot of guys
out there who don't wear masks
because they think
it makes them look weak.
Well, I saw a commercial
for a store
that can help those guys out,
and they're actually having
a special Halloween sale.
Check this out.
-Are you a big veiny meat man
who wants to look tough
while wearing
your COVID safety mask
and you also like Halloween?!
Well, muchacho, your prayers
have been answered, hombre!
Hi! I'm Lee Durango,
owner of Masculine Man Masks,
the number-one store
that sells masks
with badass designs
for tough and often scary men!
You know Halloween used
to be the only time of year
you could whip out
a badass mask,
but now we have
to wear a mask every day!
That doesn't mean
you can't make yours scary
and messed the heck up!
I have masks like Dracula
drinking a peanut butter
protein shake!
A Jack-o'-lantern
with a Tapout logo!
Frankenstein getting
his crossfit gym membership
revoked because
he got too yoked!
And a bunch of bugs
and bug guts are on your mouth
because you're, like, some
bug-eating villain or something!
Not sure if that's
a Halloween thing or not,
but I have 500
of those mother [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
But what if you're
a really Jacked-up guy
who's extra twisted,
and you don't want
just any old scary mask?!
You want one that, when mommies
see you walking down the street,
they cover their sonnies'
and daughties' eyes?!
Well, brother, I got you!
'Cause I'll show you
the scariest masks on Earth!
But make sure no children
or puppies are watching,
'cause these masks will give
them permanent nightmares!
We have a guy's mouth that has
Chucky hiding inside of it!
A werewolf who has a bunch
of food stuck in his teeth!
And the scariest mask of all,
your wife asking you,
"What are you thinking about?"
[ Woman screams ]
So, come on down to
Masculine Man Masks,
the only way to make
your mouth as badass
as my Papa Roach cover band,
Uncle Head Lice!
-Masculine Man Masks
Halloween sale is located
next to the steroid-injected
pumpkin patch
and the haunted ATV dealership.
[ Cheers and applause ]